[Music]
like I feel stealing images of civilian
infrastructure my execution what did you
cooperate maybe we cannot reduce your
sentence to so few anguish about ours
with yours truly I don't know what
you're talking about since some American
fondue party KGB black sites for
political prisoners well you'll be
tortured until you exit death
now the genital extraction waited on can
you please stay in character
please how are we supposed to have sex
if you extract my genital I don't know I
was just gonna work my way up to it and
then like do something sexy with them
okay okay okay okay
um okay now for the genital extraction
give me a sec what is your problem I
feel ridiculous here can we do something
at least semi realistic like realistic
like how like having you know sex in a
Marriott no room service with done that
so I'm a square because I don't want to
get castrated in some Soviet gulag oh no
you're square because you come to the
table with zero ideas I come up with
ideas all the time like what like okay
what if you were listen however we do
something in our own skins in a scenario
that's like vaguely plausible where you
don't cut my dick off in our own skins
yeah
fine yeah yeah fine okay can I keep my
accent though I kind of like it
I prefer God but okay fine
okay are we at the gynecologist I know
why are we here
oh right cat we are ready for your
full-body examination
my gynecologist you said you were
opening something we're grounded so I
thought yeah grounded as in like
experiment in a safe space not having a
threesome with someone we know that like
threatens our marriage she doesn't even
live here anymore since when since she
moved to Pennsylvania to be closer with
her family oh come on what you never got
to see her again what does this matter
it matters because she's my gynecologist
she's a trusted figure in my life she's
been examining me for five years she
knows my pregnancy she knows you in a
way that only another woman could know
do not stop that I'm sorry I'm getting
kind of tired can we just write and call
this please tomorrow my Pilates tomorrow
hey I'm not trying to be difficult
okay I can't to go back to Russia
I miss it you know try one more yeah
okay oh wait a minute that's your uh
your flower Jersey yeah we went is this
it's moving day five years ago we don't
I sprained my wrist yeah Oh
[Music]
what what huh isn't it sort of weird
like
you've already done this before so so I
thought the point was it's like try some
new ways to enjoy ourselves yeah yeah
just think of it like we're playing our
greatest hits this is our best hits
mm-hmm the ship-lock department in
glendale well I have my pre-baby tits
and you have the hairline with 25 girls
so I don't think it's better than that
Oh God though how does that sentence not
press you like what it's just it's all
downhill from this moment no I don't
want to have a philosophical discussion
I just wanna have sex okay please okay
that's good right yeah of course okay
okay
why don't you do what you do not to do
what you do why don't you do what you do
what to do what you do
why don't do what you do
[Music]